hello everyone I decided to show you
another game from the 1959 candidates
tournament held in bled Belgrade and
Zagreb I don't know if you remember in
my previous video between talents miss
love I said that its missile played the
caro-kann and Fischer said that all the
Soviets are playing the caro-kann
because they are afraid to face him with
a Sicilian so here we have a game
between Bobby Fischer and set aside Liga
rich one of the strongest Yugoslavian
grandmasters he is actually a record
holder he won the US Levine Championship
twelve times and in 1958 he even was
proclaimed the best athlete in
Yugoslavia so that was an extreme honor
for a chess player to you know be be
given this award the best athlete and
here he faces Bobby Fischer so I decide
sure this game as he faces him with a
Sicilian so let's see this game I
couldn't find any photos from from this
game they played but I did find one this
one it's Bobby Fischer against what
against Vito's ugly couch but this game
is from 1958 so I year before this
tournament
it was the intra zonal tournament in
Porto ROG and both of them qualified for
the candidates in 1959 so you can see
Fisher is here playing in short sleeves
it was it was the time before he started
collecting suits with the with his
genius idea of becoming the most elegant
man in the world but a nice photo
nevertheless so I do hope you enjoyed
that now let's see the game Fischer
opens with E 4 and we have c5 the
Sicilian defence Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 d 4c captures Knight captures all
standard Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
d6 now and we have Bishop to c4 Fischer
goes for his favorite move this is the
saucing attack also some awesome orders
so later call it the the Fischer's
weapon
Bishop to d7 and now Bishop to b3 and we
have g6 now going for the dragon f3 we
have Knight to a5 going after Fischer
strong LightSquared Bishop Bishop to g5
now Bishop to g7 Queen to d2
with the idea of going Bishop to h6
sometime in the future exchanging legal
rich strong dark square bishop we had h6
kicking the bishop back Bishop to e3 and
now rook the c8 so black is in no hurry
to castle now that he played h6 he can't
really castle
otherwise the h6 bone will be under
attack so we have queenside castle by
Fisher and now Knight to c4 and it's
interesting that Fisher allowed this
because one of the key ideas when
playing against this setup is you don't
want to give up your dark square Bishop
as white because it will it will be very
useful in attacking blacks King side but
okay fish roll allows this Queen to e2
and now Knight captures on e3 we have
Queen captures and only now glitch
castles so we have castles and it seems
black completed all of his development
and he got rid of white strong dark
square Bishop which is most of the time
used with the idea of Queen d2 Bishop e3
going after Bishop to h6 and then white
simply pushes g4 h 4 so let's see how
this game will turn out
g4 by Fischer so he goes for the idea
and none the same Queen to a5 by gligar
rich and now h4 and here a good idea for
legal which would have been to play
Queen to c5 as it kind of pins this
Knight to the Queen on e3 is undefended
and it doesn't really doesn't really
allow Fischer to create the perfect
setup for his attack but instead after
this h4 move by Fischer gligar rich
played east 6 we have Knight d2 e to
immediately now not not allowing this
Queen to c5 anymore and also adding
protection to the c3 Knight as the c3
Knight will be under heavy fire this
game the bishop on g7 will be eyeing at
the Queen on a5 the rockin c8 which will
be doubled soon on the C file so I
useful move this Knight to e2
rook the c6 now legal rich prepares to
double up on the C file g5 by Fischer H
captor son g5 h captures and g fat and
knife to h5 and here f4 by playing
Knight to h5 ligature stops any threats
Fischer
might have had on the H file all
so now the Queen opened up the attack on
the g5 pawn so black could easily
pressure it so f4 always a good move
plus it allows the Queen to to enter the
attack via Queen to h3 if the knight
would ever move so i useful move in a
lot of ways Glick village continues look
F to c8 doubling up on the C file we
have King Tubby one getting the King
away from the C file as the rooks are
doubled here and also it gets him away
from this very nasty diagonal as when
the position opens up in the future you
never know when this Bishop to h6 might
be in your queen to the king so again a
very useful move and here we have Queen
to b6 here of Liguria offers an exchange
of Queens maybe a slightly more precise
way of offering a queen trade would have
been Queen to c5 because now if Fischer
declines that with let's say Queen to f3
now licorice would have the option of
maybe rook to b6 and then pushing the a
pawn maybe opening up Fischer's Queen
side this way but instead he played
Queen to b6 offering a trade of Queens
Fischer played Queen - Queen to f3 and
here we have a very interesting position
black black really does have a pretty
good setup the knight on h5 is blocking
Fischer's attack somewhat the rooks are
doubled on the C file the Queen is okay
nicely placed on b6 maybe maybe maybe
sea-fog would be a better square but
nevertheless so what do you do here is
black one option is of course to try and
push immediately to try and create some
chances but now after a move like this
Fischer has the option of pushing FF 5 +
f5 would be deadly in this case for
example in characters on f5 and now rook
captures on h5 you capture the rook now
comes Knight to d5 attacking the Queen
after the Queen moves and now comes
Queen to h5 and white simply has too
many threats here there's the threat of
g6 of course going after Queen to h7 the
bishop on b3 is I in the f7 pawn as well
as the Queen so ideas like Knight to f6
check followed by Queen captures on f7
are here there are simply too many
threats and if black tries
to avoid this by playing something like
came to a fate and not allowing this
check white would go Knight to f6 all
the same
for example the create defending the f7
pawn but now e 5 as now the pawn on d6
is pinned and after something like Queen
to e7
now comes Knight to d4 and there are
simply too many threats here for example
pawn captures and Knight captures an f5
going after the Queen and after we move
the Queen let's say Queen to h7
threatening Queen to g8 checkmate the
knight on f5 is covering the d7 square
you have to defend this Bishop captures
but now pawn captures and whatever black
plays is it's checkmate
on the next move as this point is again
the pawn and Knight are covering the e7
and the g7 square so this is just one of
the variations that could arise if
Fischer is allowed to push f5 so
licorice plays rook to c5 and here here
we have a position where Fischer can
Fischer can play rook captures on h5
nonetheless but he doesn't I mean he
probably knows that this will work and
that white will be able to mount an
attack but I think he tried to do to
kind of troll the garage here because he
played Queen to d3 he said okay look at
you played rook to c5
I'm going after your d6 pawn and
probably here he gave glitch a couple of
options he wanted to see what a glitch
would play if he decided to protect the
pawn with let's say rook to c6 then
probably Fischer will go Queen T at
Queen to f3 and if legally she repeated
then Fischer would probably capture on
h5 and mounted the attack but he also
gave him some other options so glitch
thought I have a pretty good idea here I
could win upon and he thought that this
will work
obviously as he played it so he played
Bishop captures on c3 we have Knight
captures on c3 and now Knight captures
on f4
now with a tempo on Fischer screen on b3
Fischer plays Queen to f3 and here Glee
which brings the knight back Knight to
85
but now Fischer does play rook captures
on h5 so
captures on h5g captors on h5 and Queen
captures on h5 and you have a you have a
lot of options here for black how do you
defend this position ideas like rook to
h1 are coming maybe look to f1 going for
the f7 pawn IDs like g6 are coming
simply opening up the F file followed by
rook to f1 and Queen g6 so a lot of
ideas here and you have to do something
it to try and stop them all here
licorice played Bishop to e a simply
defending the f7 pawn and here an idea
like rook to h1 would would probably I
mean not probably would be winning but
Fisher Fisher decided not to go for this
as he probably saw that after King to f8
he may be thought that King would have
an escape route but actually he doesn't
if licorice would continue king to a
fate had then Bishop captures an e6
completely shatters blacks defenses F
captures on e6 now comes Queen H a check
King g7 rook h7 check Bishop blocks if
you if you if you play something like
King to d8 it's it's all the same simply
Queen to f6 check checkmate
so after Bishop blocks simply Queen f6
check King moves Queen captures King d8
and now Queen to d7 and this is
checkmate
but Fischer probably didn't want to
calculate he found another move that was
that was not not so forcing but just as
winning he played the Queen to h6 not
allowing the King to escape on f8 and
now he's preparing moves like rook to f1
rook to h1 g6 is coming and here the
garage played rook captures on c3 and he
did this with a pretty decent idea as if
if you try something like rook to h1 now
with the idea of Queen to HH then Queen
to d4
defending the h8 Square and this would
actually ruin whites whites chances of
actually winning this game so it would
be very hard for whites to win this game
now so after rook captures on c3 Fischer
simply captured played B captures on c3
and here you do have again some
options in the game glich played rook
captures on c3 another option would be
to play something like Queen - if - III
trying to get the Queen into the defense
but again you have a temple with rope to
d3 Queen has to move and now simply
Bishop captures on e6 and it's all over
if you capture then simply Queen
captures this is what check you in the
rook and c8 so are completely winning
position so after Bishop captures on c3
sorry after B captures on c3 we had rook
captures on c3 and now Fischer played g6
and now there's really nothing to look
for here as you know you have to play
something F captures and g6 was played
and now Fischer played rock - h1 and
here Queen to d4 was played simply
covering that h8 square but it doesn't
matter if you play something like King
to f7 you still run into Queen to h7
check King f6 and now Queen to h8 now if
you play something like came to g5 you
get Queen to h4 checkmate and instead if
you play something like King to e7
then comes Queen captures on c3 legal it
will be done a rook completely winning
position for white so after this rook to
h1 villiage tried Queen to d4 trying to
guard that h8 square but now comes Queen
to h7 King to f8 and now comes rope to
f1 and that's that's over although I
believe after Queen to h7 that Liguori -
resigned not really sure if he resigns
on Queen to h7 or or after King to f8
and rope to f1 but I believe it was on
Queen to h7 the reason is after King to
f8 you get rook to f1 and there is
nothing for you to do here you can block
with the rook but white simply captures
that although you can also block with
the Queen white simply capture the Queen
and lastly we will have to block with
the bishop and then comes Queen captures
on f7 checkmate so yeah that's the game
one of also one of the nicer games from
the 19 1959 candidates tournament in
Belgrade and Zagreb and although it was
really a destruction of the dragon
Sicilian it doesn't rival the beauty of
tiles game against me
slope and for some reason I I said in my
previous video that tal resigned the
game although of course miss lock
resigned the game I move 26 so probably
due to the fact that I might be I might
get too excited when I show tiles games
that might might be the reason but you
know fear not it was actually thought we
won the game and Smith's look resigned
so that's the game Bobby Fischer against
which I do hope you enjoyed it I think
the official the official name of this
game in the chess games databases I
don't believe in dragons as probably
Fischer doesn't believe in any defense
but you know that that's just him so
yeah I do hope you enjoyed that I would
like to thank hit Nima watt for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon probably with another game from
this wonderful candidates tournament of
1959 see you soon